The Daily Beast around the time that
Epstein was arrested the second time
came out and noted that Epstein had had
attended at least five meetings at the
Clinton White House with a guy named
Mark Middleton okay
um last December the Daily Mail obtained
the full visitor logs that number
ballooned to 17. it wasn't covered in
the U.S
shouldn't that matter that it goes from
5 to 17 you have this guy in less than
around two years going to the White
House 17 times and he's not just meeting
with Mark Middleton his first meeting
was Robert Rubin a former head of
Goldman Sachs
who by the way Goldman Sachs was accused
of being a major accessory to Robert
Maxwell's Financial crimes including the
stuff with the Pension funds and all of
that were involved in all of this crazy
stuff so the guy that is part you know
running basically the bank that Robert
Maxwell is very much tied to Robert
Maxwell dies and the first guy to bring
Jeffrey Epstein into the White House is
that Banker